foreign
let's run out to one of my favorite
places on planet Earth New Orleans
Louisiana and talk to Dear Marie what's
up Marie
good Dr John how are you partying what
are you up to
nothing just hanging in there
excellent what's up how can I help
yeah so um I have a question and I'm
just going to give you a quick little
rundown so my husband and I recently
celebrated our two-year anniversary and
we knew that he had a work trip a work
trip coming up for about five weeks so
anyway he's been on that trip for two
weeks the first week communication just
was not there not really talking to me
and I told him how important you know
hearing from him was especially while
I'm at home with the kids and um so
finally we talked almost at that week
Mark and he has just come to this
realization that life is so good you
know just not having any anxiety any
worries and
um just all of these doubts in his head
now about our relationship and our
marriage and I'm just I'm not sure how
to move forward with it and and what
else to do on my end
okay let me let me see let me piece if I
can piece on this together so y'all have
been together for two years and you got
you've got multiple kids or those from
another relationship
yes okay and how old are your kids
so we have a four-year-old which um he's
been in her life since before she was
one and then an eight-year-old and a 13
year old okay all right and so y'all got
married and how how old are you and how
old is he
I am 31 he's 33. okay
so y'all get married he goes on a trip
and
that peace and quiet
like so I I've got two kids and when I
travel my wife travels I'm I'm flying
out um tonight so I'll fly out
um and there will be about 12 hours when
it's it's incredible
and it's so quiet and like I can make
snow angels on the bed and there's
nobody like Hey Dad hey Dad hey Dad can
I have a snack like none of that exists
for 12 hours it's awesome yeah and then
by about hour 13 I hate my life I can't
wait to get back okay and sometimes
that's 24 hours 48 hours
um my wife can go two or three days but
she wears more of it during the week
right so what you're saying is he went
away and didn't call you didn't talk to
you didn't reach out yeah yeah no and I
was just you know I'm at home with
um so we have my two kids full time and
I'm at home with them you know the
little one wanted to talk to Daddy and
you know no no calls nothing and and I'm
missing him you know I'm like I miss my
husband I miss him around here I miss
having that adult interaction and he
just he didn't want to take that time to
call you know he's he's got buddies I
get it like enjoy your time while you're
out there but um I'm like hey don't
forget that we're here and so finally I
was like hey we haven't talked in a week
can we talk and on that phone call
um he said basically he doesn't miss
home that he just loves the freedom and
realizes that he's really been watering
himself down and conforming into our
routine which I get you know we have
three kids it's hectic it's crazy we've
got schedules and yeah but it's his
routine too I mean yeah
okay first I'm just gonna be as honest
as possible to you and I'm gonna tell
you
there's not really a road map here like
in the scientific literature I'm just
gonna tell you what I would do okay
um I would be stunned and I've been
stunned before on the show I've been
wrong often on this show before I would
be very surprised if there's not
somebody else
well you know since you mentioned that
um you know you know it's crazy how God
works like always so
um on Instagram just scrolling looking
and a picture came up and I was like oh
you know oh cool it's him like a work
function so um I clicked on it to look
and it was posted by a female and I
guess because he liked the picture it
had popped up on a suggested I don't
even know but um I looked at it and I
found out that you know the times that
he did talk to me and tell me he was
going to eat with the guys that they
hadn't hung out with any girls that that
had been false and there was this one
particular girl he had been hanging out
with on a regular occasion just you know
leaving it out and um it's not just
leaving it out
like he's lying to your face right yeah
and and I told him that I was like Hey
like I don't understand how you can feel
comfortable like lying to the person
you're married with like that's a big
deal to me and it makes me feel
extremely insecure like knowing that
you're lying and basically he said that
he did not want to get lectured or
questioned and he's old enough he knows
how to handle himself
here's what I think's happening here's
what I think's happening
I think
um he is with somebody right now
and what he's doing because he's a
coward and a child is he's gonna make
this this disintegration of your
relationship your fault
I don't like conforming you're squashing
me you're judging me you're leaning on
me you're doing these things to me and
look what happened I just had to go fill
in the blank I had to go for a week and
not talk to you so this is um I'm gonna
give you like some secret Guy Code stuff
that you're not supposed to know because
you're not in the gang right but I'm
gonna tell you if I go like on a guy's
trip we all go to Vegas we all go watch
the fights we all go do a thing right we
all go on a hunt trip on a fishing trip
whatever there is always
always a moment when everybody splits up
and calls home
always
yeah I I can't wrap my head I can't
think I'm trying to think I can't think
of a time in the last 20 years that that
hasn't happened
and if it doesn't it's a very clear like
hey I'm going to be in the woods
tomorrow and I won't be able to call out
I love you and as soon as I get signal
I'll reach out
but like so this idea like I was with
the Bros we all forgot that's stupid
because even all I guarantee you some of
those guys broke out and said hey I
gotta go call home and it's uh it's not
uncommon for everyone to be like I gotta
go call home but
most of the time guys can't wait to call
home and check in
yeah right and so you're not crazy yeah
and this I'm just going to talk to you
for a week is madness that's nuts it's
just nuts and
um it's a very cowardly exchange so I'm
gonna tell you what I would do
and this is a terrible recommendation
and so I can't recommend it to you what
I'm telling you is this is what I would
do
it's my wife
was gone and she was going on a two how
long is this work trip by the way
um it's almost five weeks and so we're
what does he do like uh he is it's
military training
well that kind of changes things is
there a possibility he doesn't have
access to his phone
no he does
um he does he's just made it clear that
like he's really enjoying his you know
life and I get it the first two years of
our marriage had been you know it's been
hard we've been having to figure out how
we can
um blend our families together we're
figuring out communication which has
been you know a really hard spot for us
yeah but you don't quit you don't quit
yeah no you know for the last
two weeks I've been reminding him that
I'm like hey I'm here for you I love you
um you know let um I want to work on
things I want to fix things because he
didn't say anything about this before he
left he's like oh a relationship is
great no it's because he's a coward what
what does he tell you what does he tell
you when you say I love you and I don't
want to work on this
dude you're not still trying out this
isn't a tryout I know and like it makes
me feel crazy because I'm like am I
crazy for myself no no you're not crazy
on any part of it no and yeah if he was
to come in and say or before he left
listen the last two years have wrecked
me in a way I didn't anticipate
and
um I'm I need a couple of weeks of no
communication because I got some hard
things to sort out in my mind
yeah and that would be a truly
devastating conversation to have in
person
and it's basically like a we're going to
take a quick like a quick two-week
three-week separation we're gonna take a
quick two or three like this me going
away for five weeks is bigger than
just
um we're gonna be a part like I I've got
to get my head screwed on straight and I
got to figure out if this is what I want
for the rest of my life
and like if that was a friend of mine I
would challenge the premise of that just
because it doesn't align with my
personal values
but that's the respectable way to do
something like that right
it's not just a ghost though your wife
so no you're not crazy
at all
um to answer like I would get in a in a
car or I would fly out and I would meet
that person directly
yeah and I don't know if that's possible
in a military base I don't know if
there's if there's evening released I
don't know any any of the details around
that but I would have to know you're not
going to just not talk you're not going
to just ghost me if you are leaving me
we're going to have this conversation
now because you mean that much to me and
my marriage means that much to me I also
know this that is not a safe situation
for everybody it's not a smart situation
for most and so I can't recommend it
what I'm saying is
it would mean that much to me that
everything in my life stops right this
second
and that becomes number one priority
yeah and I you know I felt I felt that
way you know I thought about it but I'm
like just the responses that I'm getting
from him like I I think he might be
upset you know if I went over there and
it's so I've been I've been trying to
give a mistake yeah yeah hold on hold on
why do you think so little of you Marie
like I don't want him to be upset how's
his wife supposed to feel she's getting
left via text message
like I mean and he's just gonna check
out The Vibes when he gets back I mean
come on
yeah it's just you deserve more than a
person you deserve more than this
yeah and the way you're interacting with
the way you're talking the way and as I
say like I'm almost I'd be willing I I
just I'm fairly certain there's somebody
else involved
and if there is he needs to have the
courage to sit down face to face with
you and say I've fallen for somebody
else or I am cheating on you right now
or I got married I met somebody else and
I haven't been totally honest with you
and I know that I've broken your heart
and devastated you and the lives of
these kids but this is our reality right
now
that is the noble way to handle a very
unknowable situation I don't think
unnoble's a word
but that's how you do that
and he's not and he's leaving you the
wife
dangling on the end of this line
wondering what you did
and I hate it for you I'm sorry you're
not crazy
well you have to ask yourself here's the
here's the the metric you have to ask
yourself what does this relationship
mean to you
what does
um
the marriage mean to you what does this
person mean to you and
you gotta own reality too
if you think this person's if he's been
lying to you forever and gets mad at you
for calling him on it if you think he's
been cheating on you and gets mad at you
you don't get to be my parent I'm your
wife
and you start to go oh oh you start to
like almost like watching The Sixth
Sense and they they replay those those
key scenes and you're like oh I missed
it if that's you right now then you've
got some harder conversations to have
some direct conversations but here's the
the bigger picture I want you to take
your autonomy and power back in this
relationship
because it's a hundred percent one-sided
as though he's been doing you a favor
by checking out the vibe and you're
passing the vibe test so he hangs and
then once he's out he's like I don't
like the Vibes we're gonna chill here
as though you're like a surfing spot
you deserve more you deserve more
and if he wants to call a show I'd love
to talk to him man I'd love to talk to
him
frustrating to hear this side of it oh
man